- You kinda was giving a little kids
in the sandbox a side eye.
Like bro, you better not leave that toy
'cause it might not be
there when you get back.
(light music)
- Today we are here to
try McDonald's Happy Meals
for the very first time.
- When I was little, my
parents never really took me
to a lot of fast food restaurants.
- I don't know what to
expect what I'm getting
from a Happy Meal.
I know what the food tastes like.
Now I've had McDonald's.
Will it taste a little sweeter?
- I feel like I'm getting a gift.
I had a choice of apple juice,
milk, or chocolate milk.
- I (beeps) love chocolate milk.
It is my favorite drink of all time.
- Should I wait 'til
I eat to open the toy?
That's like --
- There's always like
loose food like a fry.
You know you always get the
loose ones at the bottom
of the bag, but to get
it in a cup like this.
This is great.
- Oh, it's like 3D, kinda trippy.
- Oh, this is a Transformer toy.
So I don't know if I should
be starting with this.
(laughs)
That was good.
- So all it is is a cup with a sticker.
I can go to Legoland.
Kids can go free.
Okay cool.
I don't have any kids.
- Look at that.
That looks great.
- Life is so simple.
You just come home, do a little
homework, just hop into bed,
and just be watching cartoons.
- Yeah, I used my toy, which again,
now this defeats the
purpose of calling it a toy.
- My parents would be pissed
if they saw me eating this,
but it's good.
And I'm gonna eat the whole thing.
- This is like the cutest little fry ever.
Look at that.
In the palm of my hand.
I'm just gonna down these
fries 'cause this is easy.
I'm more intrigued with this
than I am and this stupid cup.
- I love a good soggy fry.
As long as it's hot and
it's got a nice crunch
to sog to salt ratio, we're good.
- These are so cute, so small.
It's nice that they cut it out like this.
My mom used to cut out apples like this
so it was easier to eat.
- All you want was the Happy
Meal because it had a cool toy.
Well, it was like a Disney
princess or a Hot Wheel.
This is a (beeps) cup.
I'm really sorry.
This is not a toy.
I might just sound like
a whiny jerk right now.
- I feel like to this day this
could still get the job done.
It taught us portion control.
They really had the key to success.
- This has been a great experience.
I would eat it again and again and again.
And I would've eaten it so many times more
if I could have as a kid.
- I never read nutrition and stuff but --
Who reads that?
(laughs)
(lively music)